welcome to Max Tech and this is our
review of the iPhone 15 Pro Max
now trying to decide if this is finally
the year when many people should upgrade
or maybe even switch from an Android
phone and despite my initial
disappointment at Apple's event I have
to answer with an astounding yes now
that doesn't mean that the road isn't a
little bit bumpy because I do have some
complaints and issues with it but
overall this phone passes my three-part
formula for what it takes to make an
upgrade worthy phone let me explain the
first part that is so essential for
making people feel like they got a good
upgrade is actually how the phone makes
you feel as soon as we unbox the 15 Pro
Max it was instantly obvious that this
thing feels fresh and different with
there being no way of mistaking it with
any of the previous iPhones right out of
the gate you'll feel the difference in
weight distribution and how it feels to
hold now being 10 lighter than before
and it feels just so nice thanks to
these new curved edges that feel so much
better in the hand no longer digging
into your palm like it did before but
being perfectly swaddled now part of
that has to do with the new titanium
metal that feels less grippy or sticky
like the stainless steel and as far as
the looks the titanium now looks amazing
along with the bezels that are now
Slimmer and honestly more immersive
enough that you can feel the upgrade so
overall it passes the feel test which
doesn't seem like that big of a deal but
deep down subconsciously it's actually
the most important thing when it comes
to upgrading your phone now for part two
of this upgrade formula I believe the
second most important thing is the
experiences or in other words the things
you can now experience with your new
phone that you couldn't before and the
15 Pro Max definitely passes this test
for example there are subtle changes
that are important to me like the
speakers which are now much better than
before being louder and having higher
quality just listen to this quick
comparison clip
foreign
[Music]
there are other things like this
cellular connectivity which has clearly
improved this year especially when we
tested the difference inside of our
office surrounded by concrete walls and
that can make a huge experience
difference for someone who has
previously experiencing connectivity
issues another one is the battery life
and honestly I'm not that happy with it
since I personally expected more and
over the past week I'd say that it's
basically around the same or maybe even
slightly worse than before depending on
what I was doing like gaming which I'll
get into in just a minute but there are
two things that I specifically want to
focus on the action button and the USBC
Port but first I want to mention that
Max save has been my single most
favorite feature on the iPhone ever
since the iPhone 12 and now it's getting
better than ever with tons of Max save
accessories on the market but our
sponsor ESR takes it a step further
allowing you to level up your max save
with the biggest and fastest Max save
collection for iPhone 15. now ESR has
been a long-term sponsor of this channel
but I honestly really enjoy their
products and now they have a new more
compact 25 watt three in one made for
Max save charging stand that supports
full speed 15 watt iPhone charging with
cryo boost cooling Tech which makes it
charge much faster than Apple's charger
because it keeps the temperatures cool
it also gives you full 5 watt Apple
watch fast charging as well as a
charging pad for your air pods and this
maxif charger is perfect to use with
esr's classic hybrid case with stash
stand which is thin durable has a very
strong magnet and it comes with a
patented stash stand built into the
camera bump ESR also has their 15 what
made for Max save car charger which also
cools down your iPhone so it doesn't
overheat dim your display and slow down
charging and finally they have this cool
three in one foldable travel charger
with 5 watt Apple watch fast charging as
well and you can check out the links to
all of these down in the description
below now getting back to experiences I
honestly think that the action button
was a genius choice because that mute
switch was sitting there doing nothing
for many people for many years including
myself and now the action button not
only gives you a new way to conveniently
access and control apps on your phone
but it gives you something much more
important a feeling of Freedom yes the
action button single-handedly makes the
Iphone feel a lot less locked down for
the first time in many years allowing
you to do basically anything you want on
your iPhone from unlocking your Tesla or
turning on the AC or instantly access
using the camera and recording a video
by touching nothing other than the
action button alone all the way to
opening up a full menu list of shortcuts
and finally something as simple as
playing a tune for the heck of it
this action button just gives you a
sense of Freedom which is so important
especially for Android users considering
the switch to iPhone and speaking of
that we have the USBC Port out of all
the things that surprised me about the
iPhone 15 Pro Max when I actually got it
in my hands it was by far the USBC Port
because I honestly expected Apple to
lock it down in some ways but no they
didn't everything we tried to plug into
the usb-c port worked instantly with no
hiccups or reliability issues we charged
other devices with it we plugged in ssds
to test out the external video recording
feature and even entire USBC hubs with
multiple devices connected all of them
working perfectly including SD cards we
connected it to Apple's 6K Pro display
xdr and it instantly worked showing up a
full screen video I even connected the
magsafe phone cooler from Razer and it
actually powered it lowering the temps
down to Under 12 degrees Celsius which
is insanely cold since it uses a
thermoelectric Peltier cooling system so
I decided to go all out by purchasing
Apple's multi-port HDMI adapter and
basically creating a legit gaming
console setup by connecting it to my 150
inch 4K projector using an Xbox
controller to play COD mobile gen impact
and Diablo Immortal on my couch to get
it running I connected a power cable to
charge the iPhone and a USB a cable to
run the phone cooler to ensure that
there is no overheating at all and it
worked flawlessly now yes this could
hurt your battery health so I tried it
again without charging the iPhone at the
same time to test the battery life and
after 2 hours and 10 minutes the battery
only went down to 82 percent so that's
going to support basically over 10 hours
of non-stop gaming which is more than
enough but anyway I'm shocked at how
open the USBC Port is and the feeling of
Freedom it gives you compared to
previous iPhones making it so much
easier for Android users to finally make
the switch especially since the 15 Pros
USBC Port has 10 gigabit per second
transfer speeds compared to only five on
the s23 ultra and now with that said
let's get into part three of the upgrade
formula which is actually the specs like
the cameras and the controversial a17
Pro chip with the new iPhone 15 lineup
Apple has made the one upgrade I'd hoped
for for many years they've changed the
default photo resolution to 24
megapixels across all main camera photo
modes including portraits so for the
first time in many years you can
instantly notice the difference in
quality right away Apple has put
themselves ahead of every phone out
there in terms of the default photo
output we recently did our blind camera
test between the 15 Pro Max the s23
ultra and the pixel 7 Pro and the iPhone
one by a long shot thanks to this new 24
megapixel default output along with
Apple's new smart hdr5 algorithm that is
a massive upgrade compared to last
year's 14 Pro Models sky and Cloud
details are back and it enhances colors
and Shadows on the face and sweaters and
jackets especially during the sunset
being clearly ahead of the competition
and finally we have the new 5x telephoto
lens which at first was a bit
disappointing to me because it doesn't
have variable Zoom from 3x to 5x like I
thought it would but now that we've
tried it I am so happy with it just look
at these 5x portrait photos with the 120
millimeter focal length instantly
compressing the background and honestly
for the first time ever making these
portraits look like they weren't shot on
a smartphone yes I'm going as far as to
say that this 5x camera will fool so
many people into thinking it was shot on
a pro camera because they look just that
good alongside smart hdr5 and the
impressive part is that for detail shots
it actually is quite close in terms of
detail when you compare it to the Galaxy
s23 ultra's 10x lens but low light is
where the 5x camera shines the most
because Apple's tetrapism lens design
allowed for a very large F 2.8 aperture
that lets in a lot of light and on top
of that Apple added excellent
stabilization to this lens which means
that you get incredibly good night mode
photos using the 5x camera so all in all
this is by far the best camera upgrade
on the iPhone in many many years maybe
even the best camera upgrade ever thanks
to the new 24 megapixel default mode
smart cr5 and the new 5x camera which
shoots the best portraits I've ever seen
and now let's talk about the a17 pro
chip and whether it's good or a
disappointment you've probably heard all
the people talking about their phones
overheating and getting so hot that
charging stopped working but the weird
thing is that not everybody is
experiencing this and me personally I'm
not really experiencing it either so
here's what I think is is going on it
might actually be a case of silicon
lottery so let me explain what that
means I believe that when tsmc was
making these new three nanometer chips
based on the n3b process they had a lot
of issues with yield which basically
means the number of chips that passes
Apple's efficiency standards with the
rest of them being thrown away the
yields were terrible so I think what
Apple had to do to improve the yields
and make sure we have enough chips for
the iPhones is that they had to lower
the standards for the entire a17 Pro
chip which meant that they accepted more
of them which would have been thrown out
and maybe those ones are the ones that
are experiencing more of the overheating
issues but because they had to lower the
standards that actually dropped the
performance so in order to give a good
jump of 10 CPU and 20 GPU Apple had to
over volt and overclock them adding more
power than they've ever added before for
example the a17 pro CPU can now Peak at
14 watts of power whereas the A14 a15
and a 16 were at around 10 to 11
previously and because of that when
you're opening up a bunch of apps it
causes the overheating issues maybe on
the chips that did not win the Silicon
Lottery and same thing for the GPU as
well the new a17 Pros GPU is running at
a peak of 11 and a half watts compared
to around 8 onto the previous a15 and
a16 which is 40 percent more power and
then looking at the Snapdragon 8 Gen 2
on the Android side it gives us more
performance while only peaking at around
8 watts of power so Apple's GPU is
clearly falling behind in terms of
performance per watt and it's likely
because of tsmc's low three nanometer
yields that caused Apple to lower their
efficiency standards forcing them to
overvolt the chips to get better
performance numbers for marketing but
with all that said I honestly think that
it's fine because the CPU
still in the lead being the fastest ship
ever in a smartphone and while the GPU
isn't the most efficient I'm convinced
that the new metal Shader architecture
Hardware Ray tracing and especially
metal effects upscaling support are what
makes this chip a winner just look at
these comparisons between the quality of
gentian impact with and without metal
effects and daintech just shared this
tweet showing off that the quality
actually got better with the 15 Pro Max
set to low settings with metal FX
compared to the s23 ultra at the highest
environmental detail settings which will
basically give the iPhone the lead
because it gets perfect 60fps with lower
temps and longer battery life so
basically metal effects is the way to go
for gaming in the future and those new
GPU changes are the only reasons why we
can now play AAA games on the 15 Pro
including the ones that Apple showed off
like death stranding but jumping back to
the 15 Pro Max in general I think it's
an absolute absolutely great upgrade due
to the fresh curved titanium design that
makes you feel like you have a new phone
along with major improvements like the
5x telephoto camera the USBC Port the
fun action button and the gaming
upgrades within the a17 pro chip so
hopefully you enjoyed this review
subscribing above
from ESR and one of those videos right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
foreign